Hey what's up guys we are back in the king of
random labs today I got some special guests this is
Jake and Richie the sonic dad crew tell
us what this is Richie This is sonic dad
project number 78 the marshmallow cannon
it runs on alcohol and shoots mini marshmallows so
basically this thing is like a mini
potato cannon that shoots marshmallows powered
by alcohol right this is a plastic PVC pipe
but you made it look like a metal
heatsink that's why I love Richie he to
me is an engineering genius
alright so you just set this thing out
on your desk and you got little ignitor here with
any luck hopefully I didn't put any dents in my drywall
thats more powerful than i was expecting  geez these guys
are joining me today because we're gonna
take this awesome concept and we're
going to blow it up two times bigger
which may not sound like a lot but wait
till you see the size difference you
make this thing two times bigger and
it's seven times more powerful and that
is what we're doing today
so this distance something that wants to
give you their PDF for free I tried to
talk them out of it but they insist
so somewhere on the screen here you'll
be able to click and also down the
description there will be a link to
where you can go and get their original
marshmallow cannon so how many different
segments are there it's actually
building this contraption we've got the
base the combustion chamber the barrel
and
have the igniter and fuel sponge I think
we're going to do is we're gonna break
this thing down into segments we're
going to go to different pieces together
the glasses on for safety and let's get
down to business
we got our parts laid out so we just
need to glue them together using some
PVC glue i love this stuff because you
don't have to prime at first you just
slap it on sticking together in 15
seconds
you're locked in tight
now this point the combustion chamber is
pretty much finished there's one part
that we need to add this pressure will
be a piece of PVC tubing that sealed off
with epoxy on one end but still open on
the other
now we're going to glue this into the
base of our combustion chamber and this
will allow us to swivel on the base and
even separated as one individual unit
but it will be completely are tied now
it's time to add here
alright so this unit is as complete as
we're going to get right now the next
step is to paint it but before we do
that we're going to complete the base so
to build the base these are essentially
the pieces that you're going to need and
we want to build them in two separate
chunks to begin with we're going to glue
all these together as seen here and I'm
going to glue all these together and
seeing here as well we're going to wait
on these pieces because these are going
to friction locks were basically gonna
just jam the pieces together and this
will actually give it so we don't want
to do that yet these things come
together really well we got the base we
got the combustion chamber the next part
is the heatsink this marks all the
struggles we need to cut out Richie says
the best thing that works is to take a
little screwdriver or something and poke
a little dent or did it right in the
center of that hole and drill it out
with a quarter inch bit and then move up
to a half inch bit so let's drill some
holes
alright guys so update we got our
heatsink finished and it is looking
awesome
the cool thing about this barrel is it's
got a beveled 45 and so when you have
your ammunition whether it's a potato or
papaya you can just jab it down in there
is a nice little chunk of something and
it's gonna fit right in your combustion
chamber ready to shoot that is so cool
what a clever design rich you are the
man
alright guys we got our parts painted
the paint's drying right now and while
it's drying we can move on to making
this very important component which is
now this fuel cell looks complicated
once you break down it's not that bad
basically are going to do is you're
going to take the metal rod you're going
to put into the center of the half-inch
and plug and you're going to fill it up
with hot glue and let that cool so the
rods running up straight to the center
then take your sponge and cut into
1-inch strips take an exacto knife or
something sharp and slice it right down
the center halfway deep a dab of hot
glue and hold in place and they get a
little one-inch sections sponge that you
can slide down to the bottom including a
place where it's going to repeat that
process until the entire rod is filled
with sponges it's very important that in
between each section of sponge you had a
full layer of hot glue this is going to
create a layer in between each section
of sponge the purpose of having all
these bulkheads in between each sponges
to prevent the fuel from sliding back to
one end
rendering this less effective got
teenager and alcohol which basically
means alcohol you can't drink poison it
the more surface area we can add through
these sponges the quicker the alcohol is
going to evaporate so we got the
combustion chamber and the baseball
finish we've got barrel and the heatsink
finished
we've got our fuel cell the only thing
left to do now is to put it all together
and add a source of ignition the igniter
actually isn't that difficult we're just
using our threaded cap from the top
we're going to drill a hole through the
center take one of these barbecue later
smash it open and extract the
piezoelectric igniter glue that down to
the center secured to the side twist the
wires and leave a little bit of a gap
when you press the button and sparks and
screwed together a little fuel is right
it's just for fun we put a muzzle brake
on the end here this uses a one and a
quarter inch coupling with a one and a
quarter to one inch bushing lookout
awesome thanks guys
so our cannon is assembled we're ready
to fire all we have to do is take this
barrel add a little bit of alcohol spray
to the sponge practice thing and give it
a slip and pasta you get the power so
after you fire you can just give it
about nine or ten pumps this will
circulate pressure in the combustion
chamber and push up all the old air and
because those sponges are releasing
fresh alcohol constantly you fire this
thing over and over and over again
without having detention camps
fire in the hole ok
well I guess that's to be expected who
missed over to shredded the damage
yeah that was amazing i love it
we're in business huge thanks to my
friends and sonic at for putting this
project together Ritchie has got some
amazing brains they've got a lot of
little projects on their YouTube channel
and their websites on ted.com so check
them out if you've got itchy hands
you're looking for something to build
you've got a lot of projects to satisfy
this kind of makes us feel like being
kids again in another video we're going
to take this thing out and battle-tested
whole range of ammunition so what would
you like to see this fire with it
put your comments below what kind of
ammunition we should shut down the
barrel and I might be a whole other
video so subscribe and stay tuned to see
what we do with this thing in the future
project videos Richie, that some cool
ideas for happiness we're going to plug
in this thing so stick around to see
those thanks for joining us for this
project will be looking for in the next
one not even move a little bit of
material do not remove a finger you
can't hesitate you got fully commit